joe biden is lying again he says the
border is closed but his administration
actions imply otherwise the
administration now paying 87 million
dollars to give to illegal migrants
free hotel rooms after they're called
crossing the border
joining me now with reaction america
first legal
founder and former white house senior
adviser stephen miller
so steven why are they being put
in the hotels to begin with this is a
very important point they are not being
put in the hotels
as a staging ground for removal which is
how hotels were used
in the past albeit sparingly the hotels
are being used as reception and welcome
centers
the contract you're referring to which
is now under investigation
because the individuals involved in
setting it up
were also tied to the transition
equates to 350 dollars
per illegal migrant per day they may as
well give this contract to the four
seasons
and save the taxpayers money how many
people right now
that serve this country honorably in
uniform are having trouble
people that served in vietnam people
that served in the gulf war they're
having trouble paying their housing
bills
while you have illegal immigrants
getting 350
per day in free housing services before
being flown
to their destination or by bus brought
to the destination of choice inside
america
yeah so you said this this is just a
welcome center
so they're just giving them breakfast
and processing them like what what is
actually going why do they
need a room it's a great question
because you might ask why wouldn't they
just
they're gonna do that why not just
release them right out of the border
part of it is purely for appearance sake
dhs assumes that reporters
for most outlets aren't going to follow
up to the next stage of the process
so they figure well if we don't release
them right here at the border there's
not going to be cameras there's not
going to be visuals so we bring them
just a little bit further into the
interior out of public view that's a big
factor here
the second reason is is because the
local communities will be up
in arms if everyone gets released there
so they tried to distribute them all
around the country
again that's a pr thing that's just to
help with optics the third reason why
is because it does take a little bit of
time to line up
funding sometimes through ngos
non-governmental organizations
to get these illegal migrants onto buses
or planes to the next stage of travel so
for all those reasons
none of which are virtuous is pushed off
into hotels
interesting now the secondary point
because this is important
the person that's getting the contract
worked on the transition now we were
promised
normalcy we were promised to return to
business as usual oh that's right this
is as usual is the people that are well
connected to the politicians
get the contract yeah i mean this is
just outrageous
honestly having worked on a presidential
transition
having worked obviously at the highest
levels of the white house this would
never
happen when donald trump was president
never ever
ever would this have happened in fact
president trump would have made sure if
we were doing a contract
it would be the person with the best
experience with the most efficiency
and the best savings for the taxpayer
this group doesn't
have any experience working with ice as
best we can tell they have no clue
what they're doing this looks absolutely
on its face
it looks corrupt and i'll say one more
thing
which is that this is about whether or
not this country has a border
paying for expensive hotel based welcome
centers for illegal immigrants
is categorically insane there's no other
word for it
it is actually insane no country that
wishes to survive would
ever voluntarily adopt a policy that's
why my group
like this that's why my group af legal
is fighting back against this
lawlessness you can find out more at
aflegal.org
but it would be like if president biden
came into office and announced in the
first week
hereby immediately the u.s military is
dissolved
you don't as a president have the right
to decide
which aspects of our national defense
exist and which
are erased apparently they do because
they're leaving it on states like texas
to defend this border the people of
texas don't pay
taxes to secure the border that's not
their job
it's it's up to our national government
to do that and the fact that they're not
doing it
is just sad anyway thanks steven for
joining us it's an outrage thank you